i see my patients repeating these skin
care mistakes all the time and i've
spoken to plenty of my dermatologist
colleagues and we agree this is the top
list let's get started pop in those good
old pimples as a general rule you should
not pop your own pimples if you do
attempt to pop a pimple and end up
breaking your skin barrier you risk
permanent acne scarring if your pimple
contains infected pus popping it can
spread bacteria into other pores hair
follicles and create even a worse
outbreak in fact popping a pimple can
actually delay your body's natural
healing process this is where spa
treatments come in handy pouring on
hydrogen peroxide and alcohol despite
what we've been told as kids using
hydrogen peroxide or rubbing alcohol to
clean an injury can actually harm the
tissue and delay healing the best way to
clean a minor wound is with cool running
water and mild soap rinse the wound for
at least five minutes to remove dirt
debris and bacteria wounds however that
are large deep or bleeding non-stop
should be treated by a professional you
know one with like
scrubs like this
shaving hard when it comes to how hard
you should be pressing the razor blade
down on your skin always remember less
is more the harder you push down the
more uneven the skin surface becomes
because the skin begins to dimple and
companies have tried to compensate for
this common tendency making razors that
resist shaving pressure but you will
still get a great nick free shave if you
use that light touch keeping wet clothes
on for too long i'm talking about the
rain the pool the gym whatever it is wet
and sweaty clothing can trap dust and
dirt that clogs pores and often leads to
breakouts cotton is great at absorbing
water therefore deflecting body oil but
all this high-tech performance gear that
we're wearing actually deflects water
that's why it's moisture wicking however
it also absorbs body oils and then the
bacteria feed on those body oils and
release a really gross scent on top of
it you put yourself at higher risk for
jock itch and other fungal infections
which is no fun for your skin falling
for social media fats tick tock and
social media in general is loaded with
skin care knowledge like this
and this
and this
kitty litter on my face but it's
important to remember that miracle cures
don't exist and some of the hacks we see
online are complete bs also do not
assume what works for a friend or celeb
will work for you everyone has unique
skin care needs issues and goals and
it's probably important to add that
there's a lot of surgery and
photoshopping at play online taking long
hot showers hot showers are no bueno for
your skin they might be good for your
soul but ideally you should try and keep
your showers on the shorter side and if
you enjoy hot water you should keep it
even shorter as that hot water can strip
the body of oils and dry out your skin
for my patients with eczema prone skin
hot water actually draws moisture away
from the skin and while it may feel good
initially frequent exposure can actually
exacerbate that eczema keeping small
cuts and wounds covered so many of my
patients believe the best way to let a
minor wound heal is by letting it dry
out actually keeping it covered and
allowing it to stay moist has been shown
to heal better with a healthier layer of
new skin aka less visible scar
forgetting the skin is its own organ the
skin needs to be looked after just like
all the other organs in our bodies
consider getting regular skin exams
especially if you have a family history
used tanning beds or had many sunburns
in the past knowing what's normal for
you is incredibly important as well so
if you see a mole change or a new one
appear that's definitely worth a visit
to your doctor no shade no sunblock you
really need sunscreen every day yes even
when it's cloudy raining or snowing ever
go skiing and not wear sunblock
sun exposure causes sunspots skin damage
and even lead to skin cancer using a
simple daily moisturizer sunscreen combo
is best but make sure it's at least 30
spf and don't forget to apply to the
ears and lips as they're the most
commonly missed areas skipping the good
old neck if your skin care routine stops
at your jawline you're doing it wrong
your neck needs some love too in fact
the neck is one of the first areas of
the body to show signs of aging because
the skin is thinner than on your face
also staring at her cell phones with our
necks bent all the time isn't doing us
any favors ever-changing routines and
too many products as fun as it can be to
try new skincare products doing so too
frequently can create more questions and
problems most ingredients will take at
least four to six weeks of consistent
use before noticeable changes also know
that if you have a negative reaction
it's gonna be really hard to pinpoint
the cause if you introduce two to three
products simultaneously over exfoliating
with harsh scrubs while exfoliation is
important in moderation it's easy to
overdo it with exfoliating scrubs
especially when your skin is feeling dry
overdoing it can cause tiny tears in the
skin leading to the development of a
rash-like texture and uneven tone like
patchy red blotches breakouts are
another common reaction especially small
rough bumpy pimples if you're using a
scrub on your face you should do it max
two times per week and when you're doing
it please be gentle don't scrub your
skin raw picking their skin you may not
even realize that you do it but
constantly picking at the skin can cause
irritation inflamed skin and spread
bacteria the digits or our fingers are
the dirtiest parts of our bodies and
harbor all sorts of bacteria that should
stay on the outside of our skin if this
is a nervous habit try to break it by
keeping your hands busy with something
else or perhaps asking for others to
help point out when you're doing it
without even knowing it fearing thy
moisturizer skin is meant to keep bad
things out of your body and moisturizing
is imperative for a healthy skin barrier
which is why you shouldn't skip out on
using moisturizers daily many of my
patients with oily or acne prone skin
think they should use this product less
but the reality is they should just find
the right product for them i challenged
hiram to see if he knew skin click here
to check that out and as always stay
happy and help
you